[Music]
all right
whatever
[Music]
all right
starting the Stream
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys it's Lord addict
and King David here coming at you guys
with another
r r with the Lords it's been a pretty
crazy you know week we've had a lot of
stuff going on we're currently in the
process of doing all the
things that we normally do when it comes
to stuff like PAX East and stuff but uh
King what you doing man
oh man
um
I'm going through my emails and stuff
like that right now trying to make sure
my face Fitness camera yo
all right speaking of crazy things this
week
[Music]
um
my boy uh Chris Barton
wrote his first book
all right so this is the handsome
gentleman right here my boy Chris
and um
igniting initiative huh Can you
it's it's you just went
you can hear me
I can't hear attic but
you know how strategic thinking can
Inspire your team and lead your
organization to long-term success
so it's um
it's incredible reading right now you
know and he goes you know to King David
a great guy and a great friend you know
um
so I always tell people surround
yourself with individuals that want to
do better and be better and strive to do
things that are different and out of the
box and you know my boy uh definitely
went and did that thing so um so on
Amazon you can get a digital copy these
you know just shoot up there and go to
Amazon and go uh check it out
if you you know trying to build
leadership qualities and you know work
with your team and stuff like that uh do
that
or if you just you know want to support
and have a good read um check it out
check this out man
peeking what's good baby
but uh my boy Chris uh he's
extended family and uh you know statue
collectors keep going in and out on my
end
no Pekin said I'm good
keep talking and talking here you yeah
so you know
uh he's called Spider-Man over there
with a dcxo incredible stuff check it
out if you get a chance please do so I
mean you know I encourage it you know
it's my guy so please check it out I
didn't even get a chance to hit Twitter
right
follow the show right now but you guys
are catching on recast
um a little bit later after the live but
I went to the movie theater and I saw uh
Champions with Woody Harrison
yo
it is a thought-provoking film
you know one of those uh
cheeky cheesy movies where man has a
problem man must do community service to
find the error of his ways and along the
way he learns the meaning of life type
of thing
and I I I'm a sucker for these films I
love these type of films and I think
these films are necessary but also it's
necessary to change our mindset because
I used to use the r word a lot right and
that's when you're talking about uh
mentally handicapped individuals but I
wasn't using it towards mentally
handicapped individuals
and
um
I was a fool for using this work because
this word is harmful for a handy capable
individuals the their everyday life
their struggles and stuff that they have
to go through to become and just be just
to live you know so this is a wonderful
film you know Woody uh gets uh stopped
for drunk driving and hits a police car
so you know he has to do 90 days
a um a basketball coach for Handy
capable uh
people
and it's an eye-opening experience it's
fun it's tons of laughter uh any any
reservations that you do have with the
film uh go check it out you know even if
you're going to check it out on the
streaming service after it's released
but um it's just definitely something to
watch it was something that I watched
and I saw it in the movie I saw the
trailer and I was interested in it and I
actually got a chance to see it and I'm
glad I'm able to talk about it with r r
with the Lord's with attic and the rest
of you guys but um
everybody in the chat if you can hear me
clear uh put a one up in the chat and I
was supposed to get a chance to watch
Mandalorian but I got back in the house
and
it just didn't happen that way so um
I'm definitely trying to you know uh get
a chance to see the Mandalorian after
this is over with
um
let me see
what it do working and lurking that's
right Beacon
yeah um
attic you can hear me yet
everybody can hear me but attic has an
issue
you know I think addicts uh
PC has an aversion
to all I just don't understand I'm so
could be his headset his headset could
be busted
or we know but
all right so if anybody goes to the to
our website that's lordsgaming.net I
encourage you to do so but check it out
right so on launch gaming.net I talk uh
with Ty and we do this thing called the
Lord's minute in the Lord's minute we uh
go over shows right now we're doing a
bad batch from
and I love the bad batch right I love it
because one I didn't I wasn't a clones
War dude when everybody's watching the
Clones War I just thought it was a kid's
cartoon and I just was like you know let
me stay away from that but nah it's
actually where a lot of the the lore is
in in in Star Wars right so you have
Anakin Ahsoka growing up Anakin uh you
know becoming or uh
eventually Darth Vader but him maturing
during this space right and they fill in
all the gaps and then you have
um Obi-Wan becoming you know General
Obi-Wan Kenobi uh in the Clone Wars and
then you got to actually see what
happens with Order 66 when they when
they actually initiate Order 66 and they
started going and killing the um the
Jedi right and the bad batch is a group
of
um
that were defective right so that's why
they call them the bad batch they don't
think the same as other clones because
all the Clones is like uniformed so
that's that's the cool thing about it
right they all got like a like mine when
they're going to fight
these dudes don't right you have record
you have uh Tech
um what what's what's the what's the
other one
um cross hair
and Echo right and Hunter
it's five of them right and it's like
Voltron so they they came I'm sending
another link to zoom on
in your email I'm done I'm done messing
with them when I this I love this app
literally it doesn't work half the time
I'm not stressing myself over it anymore
so I'm sending you right now we are
abandoning this stuff and we're going
back to I'm going to do all Zoom with
this I just have to do more work every
week like
yeah I don't know I'm done stressing
over this
but uh get right back to you in a second
all right can you hear me
yeah see it's it's ridiculous I I don't
understand that app I just don't like
uh we're still live though it's just it
just frustrates me man
oh that's switched over
what dude
the the stream went dead
no it's still alive it's just I haven't
put our cameras in there yet oh okay
yeah so they they they should still be
able to hear you let me double check
I I'm just I'm done dealing with uh this
is King talking to you from the void
now if you can hear the sound of my
voice
stay calm relax
don't fight it
do not
wiggle or scream well they can
definitely hear you
[Music]
know that I have you where I want you
let's let the crowd
see what I have for you
[Applause]
they love it so much now
we should be getting right back into
scene yeah it's like I said guys I I
apologize for the
for that stuff what happened is like
it's a lot easier for me to use their
their stream Labs stream stuff because
it because it puts up exactly where
everyone needs to be
and see now I'm having to go through
here and do zoom in general and it's
just it's just frustrating because
it's like half the time I hear them half
them I don't hear them and it's just
frustrating that
you know I have to go through all of
this trouble because
it doesn't work the way it's supposed to
he said Joe was right that is all and
all a good night
what up giant ghost whatever Achilles
AJ H what up We Still rocking hold on 21
in
yeah here we go yeah so you know it is
what it is we'll just have to use this
maybe I can find a way
to
do it to where everything works the way
it's supposed to because now my camera's
not working
and zoom I don't know what's going on
it's always something with this man it's
always something what it is is we're
doing stuff that we wouldn't normally do
there's a lot more moving parts to this
show than there is on IOP
and so it's like we're giving a lot more
stuff the opportunity to just mess up
for no reason
so well we're back uh you know what
I appreciate the the patience with you
guys uh no right now we uh you know we
was talking about going on with um
this stuff going on at uh
what was you talking about when I
couldn't hear you well I was talking
about my boy's book I was talking about
a uh igniting initiative uh my boy Chris
Barton's books
um he's a friend of mine real good dude
statue collector Family Man loving
husband great father
you know and um team leader and Builder
uh hell of a guy and he got a chance to
write his book which is on Amazon
right now you can get a digital copy or
you know you can get a hardcover I got
the hardcover you know it's not a lot of
pages you know so you don't have to you
know see oh I I won't be able to get
through the book nah it's a total of I
can tell you right now
it's a total
of 20 chapters
and
78 pages
all right
Four's a legend with the two dollar
Super Chat 65 is a good movie people
should check it out oh I'm definitely
going to get into 65. I'm definitely
going to get into 65. uh
um it's a good it's a good run
um we'll you know leap into that stuff
but um hey definitely check this out how
to how strategic thinking can Inspire
your team and lead your organization to
the long-term success
definitely check it out my boy uh
Chris Barton fantastic dude so
we uh
welcome to the r r with the Lords like I
said I want to apologize again for uh
the technical issues
um I'm abandoning that that format which
sucks because literally all I have to do
is just sing King invite sends them
exactly where he need to be but for some
reason they like we ain't doing that you
know uh it is what it is on that end uh
first off I want to say that I
appreciate all the support on patreon
you know uh we are actually getting up
to the episode before last of the season
finale of King uh with Attack on Titan I
think he he he the episode of day
literally just went out of King playing
uh King reacting to the little first
part of the fight between Aaron and the
female Titan I got chainsaw man I think
that should be finished here pretty soon
so you know there's a lot of content
over there man I think I'm gonna start
um
I I need to catch up on my hero and
after I finish my hero then I guess I'll
go to one punch man because for some
reason yeah if somebody's in the chat
people be capping for that for that no
one punch man is definitely that wave is
that Vibe one punch man
is is in a world of monsters and
superheroes he could punch you one time
and stop your life I love it I love it I
just don't like the concept of that I
think that's the issue I got to get well
for that concert oh really hard and and
gets to become the one of the strongest
people in the world oh my God you know
what I mean
it made like the concept of it makes no
sense exactly like that 90 of all animes
make no sense they rap you they wrap you
in the world and if the world hits it
hits I mean this world uh basically was
a win for me it's probably right after I
finished Naruto
um I think the second
um anime uh you know recent anime that I
got into because you know I used to be
into anime before you know first of the
North Star uh Cara uh what is that um
the overfeen you know stuff like that
ninja Scrolls you know movies you know
stuff like that but these new animes are
a little bit different they turned into
um soap operas so
I feel like they're better Pace though I
feel like anime these days are better
paced to anime back then back then I was
making movies
they yeah but why are they though like I
I feel like a lot of that was like a
Bible bro what I said a cure is a Bible
it's it's fisted a North star
these these
uh berserk bastard these these those
those animes are different these enemies
now are made for engagement and they
give you small bite-sized bites like the
episode doesn't beat more than 10-15
minutes actual content you know
um and that's that's cool it's for the
attention span of nowaday chill children
so and adults I guess too so EJ said
King what is your all's opinion on Demon
Slayer actually that is King's next
anime he's got to react to after Attack
on Titan yeah uh he I was a little story
I was gonna go see demon slay in the
movies yo attic was like where you going
or something about to um go out to the
movie theater right now and go catch
this uh movie yo I I highly you know
tell everybody get Regal unlimited if
you're a movie or right so
um he was like don't do it and I was
like could you give him the reason why
Atticus pretty much
it's just
it's just the beginning of the new
season uh and King hasn't watched
anything prior to so he'll go into this
like it would be different if it was
like a movie that's not related to the
anime but like their movies demon
Slayers movies is pretty much like the
first season of the next the first
couple episodes of the next season and
that's why I was like no your best bet
is to just finish Attack on Titan then
by the time you get to Demon Slayer I
feel like you'd be at a time where you
won't have to you know move between
these things because I have a feeling he
would have watched that it would ruined
a lot of information that's gonna happen
now
um and then when you the last season uh
the last season it was pretty much
they started it by fighting
um another Demon Slayer yeah and I feel
like you would have watched that and it
would have interrupted you know the
stuff that you're watching now I hope
you guys can't hear that yeah I can hear
that what the hell is that someone Leaf
blowing outside you know he's getting
away from my window now so yo you know
what I like my my type of animes are
like the Kenshin tensei or um I think
you elected on Ragnarok
um I I I'll see my my joint is really
mono e mono like Baki and stuff like
that and you know what moves they got
like what what style he's gonna pop out
with and that's all comes from watching
karate movies back in the days where you
know somebody like um snake and Eagle's
Shadow right and Jackie Chan and stuff
though you know what we can do actually
that would be interesting is after this
real quick we can react to the season
two trailer of attack on tighten before
you catch on to this to before you start
the new episode because I think it's
only like a minute and a half long but
put up there that way you know they you
kind of get a little sense of what's
going on because uh They Don't Really
spoil a whole lot so you know we might
do that put up put on the um the patreon
for today would be like a bonus content
because I got content going up on
patreon until like the 15th of next
month yo what I want to do is I want to
get to a point where
um I do uh live Recaps of old fights
like uh and like five deadly venoms
right where you have uh snake versus
Toad that epic battle like yeah
talk about the death battles no well not
death battle not those like actual Okay
so
um when back in the day back in the days
when you were driving movie theaters
Shaw Brothers run run Shaw and run
Michelle
um they would put out these uh karate
movies which a lot of this anime is
based off of right so then you would get
these classic battles like
um us like in Super Ninjas when they
actually come up to the wooded ninjas uh
and that first fight right there and
they lean up against the tree and the
guy steps off the tree and his whole
back is full up with spikes and he falls
out dead
um so it's it's it's battles just you
know uh oh like uh what is it eight
pentagram
uh Kung Fu bad stuff uh into the into
the Shaolin
um uh Shaolin versus ninja or Shaolin
versus llama those those movies really
good stuff man
awesome man that's what's up that I mean
I want to do that and and have some form
of Engagement but I want people that
haven't had a chance to see it or people
that do remember it and come back and
just relive those moments so we can get
Cog I'm pretty sure that we can get you
know sovereign
one or two times just to do like shorts
of those and um just to see how attic
I'm gonna see how attic you know uh
digest that type of stuff you know I
don't know
we'll see man we'll see uh you know
right now we we do got a lot of a lot of
content going up for you guys
um what I think is interesting yo he
said the Classic live oh
you better stop saying your prayers
cause you're gonna die today
[Music]
oh my God hell yeah
all right enough of all that so let's go
over to the first topic of the day it's
scream you know scream six oh you're
talking to me tell me about it because I
didn't get a chance to see it yeah King
messed up and right put a reservation
yeah you put your talent there it was
your stupidity not mine so you'll check
it right I'm not even gonna show my face
because that shows my face on the app
but okay so I had some time today after
I got off work
and I said yo you know what I'm gonna
run to the movie theater to catch the
earliest show in the screen and they
said they had the 4D showing a stream
and I said old hell yeah I could catch
it at 4D sitting in the chair rocking
with all the sweat and everything and
the screams I said I'm definitely gonna
do this
book The Time Is set 11 10.
hell yeah I sat in a parking lot and and
did it got up I walked confidently to
the guy at it confidently I showed him
my phone he scanned it and it said
invalid uh code
what
scanned it again invalid code called
over the manager I'm like y'all got it
wrong invalid code she's looking she's
like yes oh wait a second that's the
Kaufman theater
I had the whole egg face I'm like ah
buddy so I'm like what do you have
earlier that I can see because you know
Scream the next the next showing of it
the the official showing at that movie
theater was two o'clock
so they was like you got we got
champions
and I was like okay the Woody Harrison
film with the handy capable dudes I said
I'll check it out so I wound up seeing
that so I'm not able to give my input on
screen today that's my bad addict went
what 45 minutes away to go see this film
yeah I pretty much you know because the
movie theater in my facility got shut
down
because AMC doesn't want to you know
really invest into the movie theaters
they buy so that's their fault but I
went and watched it and I actually
really vibing with it man you know first
off I'm Gonna Keep It spoiler free
because I do want you guys to have a
little bit more uh
could not I don't even know the word
right now so pretty much how Scream is
is
King like say I says I like the nothing
but like slasher stuff I do enjoy
slasher movies but I like more movies
than just slasher stuff he's just he's
being very un unrealistic when it comes
to that attic likes a lot of movies he
like a lot of mushy movies man he likes
to get me to watch mushy movies mushy
movies what is a notebook and stuff no I
never tell you to go watch The Notebook
you gave me some no you ain't tell me
the notebook but you told me a mushy a
mushy show it was mushy yo your girl
didn't like it mushy what was it
I forgot what it was
all right MF God Doom definitely kid
with the Golden Arms to hell yeah yo
what the what are they talking about you
fell asleep on game one day I don't know
what they talking about I think they
joking maybe I was joking like I was
asleep I don't know okay
yeah I definitely didn't fall asleep on
day but I don't know I might have
because uh I I think I was up for 15 16
hours that that episode
who knows man who knows I went to sleep
right after it I don't think I fell
asleep on it I think that's I think
that's not being fair I was pretty
active during that podcast you know
maybe you fell asleep so you thought I
fell asleep that might be it you know
that might have what happened scream
scream's a good movie man I I think
scream is one of those things where
I felt like screen five was a really
good step in the right direction I think
uh uh Jenna the chick who plays um
Wednesday does a really good job in here
you know she has a sister in here they
continued that that storyline from
Scream five and I think they're doing a
really good job you know his sister
obviously is the
is this is the the daughter of Billy
from the original one yeah so I'm
curious man I'm curious how they're
going to really pull this off and one
thing that I noticed because I know that
they they came out and said that that um
that Sydney wasn't going to be in this
one
and she's been in the last couple of
these of these ones and I was really
curious on how a movie was going to be
able to carry on without Sydney because
Sydney's the OG you know Sydney Gail
and
and I'm really I'm very they did it in a
way where at the movie I realized
because they do bring her up they
explain why she's not in the movie but
they did it in such a way but by the end
of the movie I forgot Sydney was even
supposed to be there you know what I'm
saying yeah uh so it's it's one of those
things where I feel like they're doing a
really good job keep in mind when you're
up to scream six six installments of a
franchise people generally start to
opt out around that they're done with
the franchise but I was out like around
uh screen three or four yeah well screen
three I think is the worst screen by far
but Scream Six yeah one of them I was
just like you know what I'm done with
this hey you know what's sad because I
had I was gonna surprise you but if we
can't do it now because you didn't watch
it but I had
we were gonna we were going to rank all
the screams
oh okay so sorry yeah so you can't do
that necessarily because you know it was
in New York so yeah hey man I'm listen
I'm definitely gonna go see it because
this weekend I gotta go see Shazam
Shazam comes out on Friday which is
tomorrow why don't we watch that instead
of uh
of um what is what are we watching at
Pax
John John wait why don't we watch as
that John Wick like because uh Tuesday
we have a show and Tuesday we'll be
talking about Shazam ah see the I gotta
come back on Sunday and go watch Shazam
between Sunday and Tuesday I'm gonna be
real with you that might not be
realistic with me
because I gotta drive another 30 40
minutes to go watch Shazam
[Music]
if my flight wasn't I don't know maybe
it's a screen VR Christopher Hall what's
good baby yeah yeah yo Sony Sony might
get that done I heard um this is a 350
uh cable that you can hook up to your PC
and use your PlayStation VR as a TV
screen
I think I think scream is a step in the
right direction when it comes to this
now it does look like they're not going
to really Captivate on Sydney anymore oh
it looks like she's out of the show the
movie entirely I guess there was some
kind of dispute on pay like they wasn't
offering her enough money they were
probably offering the other women more
money than her and she probably fell
away I get it I do but if you like
realistically put it maybe they should
just pay her what she wants you to come
back to give her like her exit out of
the franchise yeah yeah because it's
just yeah the only way you're really
leaving the screen franchises if you're
dead because to me it's like
if you're not in the movie you need to
[__] because even though I felt like six
was good it was a really good for one I
would the only one I would put above it
is maybe two in one okay maybe is is
this thing like set at Halloween time at
least yes
okay okay because I'm I'm watching
homeboy in the train station and I'm
like in New York That Ain't Gonna Fly B
like we catch you on the train with a
scream mask You're Gonna Catch these
Knuckles but yeah yeah and I think that
even if seven comes out and seven is
going to come out I think they scheduled
another three so even if seven comes out
people are always going to wonder where
is Sydney where is Sydney yeah we got to
bring Sydney back just to kill him you
really like realistically you gotta
breed her or or you know what is it
screen seven She gonna pick up the phone
hello
you know what would be crazy is because
Sydney I always thought it would be
great because in this one they carry on
the sisters starting to to Really
capitalize on her her dad's genes you
know what I'm saying because in the in
the last one she went crazy and stabbed
homeboy for like 15 minutes it was like
so she clearly they are pulling at that
she is Billy's daughter you know what
I'm saying the original killer from
Scream one so he's the Jeepers Creepers
reborn is on Hulu
isn't that really bad I was told that
was a bad movie
the last Jeepers Creepers 3 was horrible
you know what's sad man we're gonna have
to do a whole podcast dedicated to
butchered sequels that just ruined the
franchise yeah this is true I'm gonna
have to get like on my tablet I'm gonna
have to start putting bad we'll talk
about here in a second because I don't
want to mess up the the recording for
screams video
I it'd be cool if in Scream seven or
eight let's say they just
Sydney's not in six she's not in seven
but you see the sister the older sister
starting to lose her sanity because
they're trying to act like oh it's
Billy's daughter obviously she's
eventually gonna go there and then in
Scream eight
the killer Sydney and she came back
because she started realizing that these
daughters are losing their damn minds
and it just gave you the script yeah it
most likely they would never turn Sydney
a bad guy but because you would have to
do in a way where I would feel like
they would have to ride Sydney's
character off by dying and then a couple
movies later she ends up being the
killer because you have to here's the
thing until Sydney's dad people are
gonna assume that she's always gonna be
the the always gonna be ghosts
but if she's dead and they wait a movie
or two
then they play any wu-tangs on
no they might have I don't know who
you're talking about
I've never seen it out because if they
was playing Ghost Face Killer
oh my God what one thing I will say is
Jenna they are the chick who who plays
the younger sister I just put her on the
screen so you guys know who I'm talking
about
she she she she's I think her sister Sam
did better you know she she was the the
highlight of the show you didn't this
chick didn't really get a lot of play
time in Scream five but I felt like she
got a lot more play time though it's a
lot of death and murder yes there's very
unique ways of killing people they yo
tell okay I'm gonna I'm gonna spoil just
a little bit let me put on the spoiler
thing for oh I can't do it because I
have to change the thing I can't do it
so let's not do anything so no no right
now I'm spoiling for 35 seconds and it's
not really spoiling you guys seen it I'm
just telling you how the scene went a
little bit so you saw the scene the
trailer was with uh with Ghostface with
the shotgun yeah yo tell me how that
scene starts with them running in there
Ghostface shows up and you know how Okay
the two girls are in the convenience
shop is good we good you know what I'm
saying Ghostface shows that there's like
I don't care you guys ran into a highly
they're too to to a highly crowded
convenient so start slitting people's
throats going through the convenience
store like like he it was like one of
those things because I ain't never seen
that King I ain't never seen Ghostface
walk up into a gas station and then
people's like what's up what's sitting
there trying to pull up the ghost face
and he just starts stabbing fools like
no wonder you loved it he just like and
then what's funny is the the the gas
clerk pulled up and was like what's up
you know what I'm saying got a shotgun
you ain't doing nothing so Ghostface
starts running because obviously it's a
shotgun but then obviously somehow
Ghostface gets the shotgun I'm not gonna
really spoil too much of that sitting
there walking down the the convenience
store and the girls are hiding in the
lanes and he's just like move so I can
shoot you
and I'm just like wow man wow there's a
couple really good iconic moves that's
in this there there's this one port
where um you know you know how they do
the the classic clean the blades yeah
they do that in a really and Chad don't
put it in the chat but if you know what
I'm talking about at the end when they
did the clean the blade thing man it was
it was lit it was I was like oh snap
because I ain't never seen that before
they did it in a unique way
um there are some unbelievable stuff in
here people getting stabbed that I
believe you know
if they find a way to keep them around
this this that that that's dumb like
because I feel like
if you're in a slasher and you're in a
situation where no one would live there
should be no reason you should live
but they but obviously they want to keep
these people around for for sequels and
stuff so you know it is what it is I I
do recommend you guys go watch Scream
five six uh I I do think it's a
fantastic movie it is popcorns is it
attic I'm gonna give it let me give it a
four four four
out of
the way he was talking about I thought
it'd be five o'clock
I I it definitely is closer to a five
than a four but I can't give it a 4.5
you know there are always little things
that they did that I feel like they
could have improved on but for the most
part this movie was a fantastic movie it
did exactly what I would expect from a
scream six and I think maybe that's the
reason it's like getting that 0.5
because they played it safe you know for
the most part this is what I expected
from a Scream movie it's not what I
didn't expect from a Scream movie and I
feel like in order to get that perfect
score from me you got to give me stuff
I'm not expecting if you just give me
the overall Logistics of what the normal
boxes franchises okay you know I
expected that you guys did it well but
you didn't do anything that I felt like
was out of the ordinary so that's why
they didn't get that 0.5
all right all right so uh you know what
what you want to go to the next 60 65
man 65. I actually when I was looking up
stuff on the
the
for the thumbnail tell me what 65 is
about man tell me what 65. first first
of all if you're a fan of Adam Driver
Adam Driver is kylo Ren uh in the Star
Wars Universe if you're a fan of Adam
Driver
this is his acting moment like I'm
pretty sure he has other acting moment
films right and um
this this this film first of all this
film has
four
actors
total
four actors who who's the actors who's
in this movie well um you can look up
the cast you know I'm uh the other
actors are not known actors to me
um but it's a total of four actors in
the whole film
and you know Adam Driver is the most uh
well recognized character I mean uh
actor if you're gonna go see the film
you're definitely gonna go see it for
Adam Adam's uh acting and you're a fan
of his work right
this film is set
65 million years ago
so
he is uh they they they start off with
him on a planet and he's with his
daughter and his wife and I guess he's
um he goes across the universe and he
takes people across the universe but he
says you know he does jobs
and
he goes away for like two years at a
time I guess traveling across the
universe
and his daughter has this condition they
never go into the condition that she has
and the fact that he has to go on these
trips that's the only way that he's able
to fund these trips uh I mean uh fund
her medication as a medication
apparently cause a absurd amount of
money and this is the only thing that's
keeping her alive him going on these
trips so this one trip he's uh the pilot
of a ship and on that ship it has 15
passengers 15 other passengers other
than himself and they're in chronogenic
uh uh suspended animation right and he's
traveling the space waves while while
he's traveling the space waves he hits
an asteroid belt
hits the Astro belt the asteroid belt uh
breaks the ship in a way that he has to
crash and land the planet he crash lands
on is Earth 65 million years ago
the asteroid belt that he hit is the
asteroid that comes and destroys the
dinosaurs
oh just yeah to plot twist he lands he
has so much Advanced Tech now the full
name of the film is 65 million years ago
a visitor crash lands on Earth but they
didn't go with all that title they just
went with 65. and he you know he crashed
the lands and when he crashed lands
remember at that period of time
there are no humans the indigenous
population there is uh reptilian right
uh some form of reptiles that are there
highly intelligent uh carnivorous
reptiles that are Primal in nature and
you may think some of them have uh uh um
a resemblance to the dinosaurs that you
see when you go to the museum they are
close in nature to it but
I'm gonna say that this movie out
Jurassic Park's Jurassic Park that's a
big statement though that's a big
statement you know why I got to say that
attic because it just feels like to me
Jurassic Park for the sake of Jurassic
Park just keeps going bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger it's like when you
first do your first prank
and you gotta just really uh just outdo
yourself like boot gang remember how he
started doing stuff that was really
absurd and it got to the point where
it's laughable right the last I think
Jurassic Park world where
um what is it uh this guy
um from Guardians of the Galaxy he he
has to raise a velociraptor blue
still stupid stupid story uh but this
this is so Primal this is so basic this
is so very tight-knit
the world is alive
uh the scene setting is is
of voluminous it if it feels it feels
like it's it's not small sets right and
it's a small cast
again when I say they out did it they
they kind of did now I'm also gonna say
this is a movie of phobias
full of phobias if you're claustrophobic
this is going to give you agita if
you're if you have fears of being alone
this is going to give your heart
trepidation if you have fear of darkness
this this thing is going to play Mind
Tricks on you it's crazy that he finds
One Life pod
that's alive
that's alive he sets out because they're
beacons all over detect that he has is
nice and this this is Tech that hasn't
been used in other movies you know how
sometimes you see other movies and you
see similar Tech you would expect it to
be like alien Tech like uh if you're any
scene any of the Sigourney Weaver Alien
movies they all use the same grid type
of bass uh sounding stuff
you would think that they don't they
come up with their own Tech they come up
with their own way of how they map the
world out and for the most part it's
pretty much believable they they made a
world
so
he goes out to this uh to get the life
pod and in the Life part this is this is
really not spoilers because I'm gonna
stop at this point he finds a girl
it's a young girl right so now I'm
sitting there like oh this is the Adam
and Eve story
I said I said oh I see what they're
doing now right this is the Adam and Eve
story not not to be the case but
there have an impending uh clock over
their head because the asteroid in the
sky like I told you is the asteroid that
is going to destroy the dinosaurs
this is a gripping film I was well
entertained for the time that I did get
a chance to watch it I thought Adam
Driver and the young girl which they
don't speak the same language she has a
weird language that she's speaking sort
of like Hawaiian uh language and he's
speaking English
so it's it's it's
a very heartwarming film and is a plot
twist to it that changes how you see
things and Adam Driver delivers this
film I mean he is in this film he's an
action star I mean if you thought him
being kylo Ren was an action star I
thought he was a whiny baby as kylo Ren
he comes across as an adult as a man
taking charge and and leading this young
girl to safety type of thing it's a
really really good film I give it full
popcorn addict I really wish she was
able to see this film uh to give your
input on it because I know you were you
would have had a good time with it
because it's Parts in it it is so
Soul attic so
just to clarify
he interacts with the Dinosaurs right oh
yes he interacts with it so is that like
an obstacle or is it like a joke
obstacle where they claim it's an
obstacle but he actually has technology
enough to where he can navigate through
them without much issues
um
no no no it's an Ops oh so he he's got
technology but nothing to that degree
because he didn't expect them there he
he has you know back up off me stuff you
know uh stuff that that is capable
but it's limited his Supply is limited
you know because he didn't expect to get
stranded on no planet
oh shout out to Forza Legend with the
two dollar Super Chat it has a horror it
has a horror elements to 65 honestly yes
it's it's it's a very like I said the
phobia in it the horror in it
it's it's going to it's going to pull at
you it's it's a film that's going to
pull at you
okay I can feel that I I can definitely
feel that you know we'll get we'll come
back to that when I watch it you know
we'll come back to that because it's
probably gonna be when that when that's
when that thing hits DVD at this moment
man I don't know man because now when I
gotta do this 40 minute drive I gotta be
selfish of what I'd be doing that with
uh 65 definitely you know it's got four
stars from King definitely go watch it
man I know a bunch of you you ain't 40
minutes away from a movie theater it's
probably right across the road from some
of you so you can go watch 45 and you
know come back and uh to tell us what
you think about 65 you know
I said I like how they built the tension
With The Dinosaurs in 65. it wasn't
trying to be a spectacle but rather
suspenseful to make you feel anxious
during moments of pure silence that's
exactly what I'm talking about
when I say they out Jurassic Park
Jurassic Park so it feels more like a
Survivor movie than Jurassic Park did
because Jurassic Park they felt like
obstacles but they didn't feel like you
know that the
the actual
you know what's what I'm looking for you
know that the actual dinosaurs was like
besides some of them like the smaller
ones I felt like they put a little bit
more if behind how much of a threat they
was but I've always felt like the bigger
ones ain't really a threat you know what
I'm saying like and the ones that
everyone looks at man the ones that
everyone looks at so that's it for for
um you know I think that's all you had
to really say Nick King yeah that's
that's about it you know just a little
synopsis for you to go get it so you can
get a little background feel of the
movie but you you would definitely enjoy
the movie If you happen to wait for it
on your your favorite streaming device
or you're gonna pick it up at the store
or hard copy or you're going to go to
the movie theater and you just have a
date night and you just saw everything
there hey man go check it out yeah go
check out 65 guys
all right here here we we know one of
the main events was man we we know uh
Last of Us officially
has ended we have seen every episode
that's in Last of Us uh so you know
first off let's go over this I do want
to go over you know this episode episode
nine and I want to just give a bass you
know what we thought about the whole
season I do want to hold a lot of our
bars because I do plan on bringing in
one or two people and doing like a
full-blown spoiler cast on the first
season of this uh but right now let's
just go over you know episode nine of
The Last of Us
you go first
this episode made me cry
this episode
made me cry because
I got the heart out of Joe
and
I mean not even talking about how
the episode started
where you can get the origin of Ellie
which was masterful shout out to
Neil druckman
um
but
the fact that Joel
really got a chance to express the Ellie
what she meant to him
what was some of his his his his darkest
what was his darkest secret
[Music]
um
I think that meant a lot it meant a lot
because it it lets you know
that he would fight the Devil Himself
than to lose this kid
because he already lost one kid and that
one kid turned them into the the loss of
the one kid turned him into something
that was unrecognizable by himself when
he looked into the mirror
um
so he knew how precious this kid was to
him and
I just thought
those moments
was absolutely brilliant I mean and it
gave you the feel of the game
I remember the last scene very vividly
of course I had to relive the scene
again when I played the last of us too
but
um
it's just certain key moments where they
expanded on the dialogue between Ellie
and Joel
really showed you they picked the two
most capable individuals to play these
uh these characters and I think they
they did a great job in picking both of
these characters I mean these these
these actors to play these characters
all right so episode nine I felt like
was a good episode
um they did the the hospital scene
extremely well
um for the most part I have no issue
with episode nine I think that it was
definitely one of the better episodes I
would say you know top three I think
episode five episode one and then
probably episode nine uh you know I
think episode two was okay there's some
weird stuff in episode two uh but for
the most part
when it comes to episode nine
out of the park you know when
the chase down and this was going on in
the hospital you know when all that was
going down
I felt like that was one of the few
times I saw Joel's Joel
like that was Joe uh most of the time I
don't I don't get it man most the time
I don't see Joel as the Joel that's in
the game and I get that that's a me
problem maybe I am looking at it too
much Through The Eyes of the video game
but it is based on a video game it's not
based on anything else and I I get
annoyed when people tell me that I have
no right to feel that way when I look at
something like
like a book like Lord of the Rings you
know
um Harry Potter
when they say when the book readers
complain about something they didn't do
right in the movies right I don't hear
people saying well go read the book
I don't hear that
I'm sorry when comic book people
complain about the way MCU is portraying
something in a movie I don't hear go
read a comic I mean I I did I just had
this hell ever born shout out to ever
born Saga I mean because he went on the
rant on Twitter about how MCU is
destroying the Hulk or destroyed the
Hulk and how everybody got their chance
at Thanos and I told them then go read
the comic books or go watch the cartoons
you know um but I feel like it's still
valid criticism though it's still it's
not crazy listen I respect your opinion
to have it you're yeah you're able to
have your opinion you're able to say if
it's wack to you if it's good to you
you're able to say all these things and
there's nothing wrong with you saying
stick to the script
you know there's nothing wrong with that
I feel you I feel you but the biggest
thing that we got to talk about when it
comes to episode nine is is the popcorn
ratings man what's that popcorn rate
man we didn't even dig into the fact
that what happened with Joel and and
she all we gonna do the spoilers or no
yeah right now I can't put on the screen
unfortunately guys but we're in spoiler
territory uh you know what I'll go ahead
and start setting up that spoiler screen
for the spoilers but you guys gonna have
to uh just barge with me for a second go
go okay so while while he while he's
doing it I'll start doing the spoilers
I'ma tell you spoilers right now
the the the the this the episode starts
off with a girl feverishly running
through the fields
escaping what we already know is to be
uh clickers or a horde or something's
chasing us she's she's running like the
devil but come to find out she has she's
pregnant with child that she makes it to
this abandoned house and it's in the
middle of the field and she makes it up
to the top of the steps and she props a
chair against the door
as she puts her back against the wall
and she takes a blade out and she sits
there and and if you're very astute
individual you would realize that that
blade is the same blade that Ellie has
to this day
so if you didn't put one-on-one together
and you didn't make two yet
I'm like oh my God this this this this
has to be Ellie's moms
what's gonna happen
and
collect a buses through the door but
it's not a fully grown clicker it's it's
an infected
yeah it's ironic it sounds like a
clicker but you know it's on a boy and
he and it jumps on like a harbor shark
and she's fighting this thing and she
stabs it in the neck pop pop pop pop pop
and as she stabs it in the neck she
pushes it off
the baby's born
the baby comes out so she takes the same
blade and she just had in this dude's
neck
and she cuts the billable cord
then she looks at a leg and she realized
she was bit and now I gotta go back and
watch this thing because I don't know
how the hell did it bit her thigh I
ain't see his face go down there to
snatch it but
um
bites a thigh
and uh
damn man and then you know
seeing ships and uh soldiers
uh fireflies come up there and
we um
have this scene
tell me about that scene that you added
when the fireflies arrived what was you
thinking
uh I kind of at that point when I saw
her I knew who she was so I knew it was
a flashback right so it wasn't really
like
at that point
everything that is in relevant because I
know the the outcome of that situation
you know what I'm saying uh I I knew who
it was I was kind of curious how you
know she never really acts like she's
known Ellie her whole life like she they
kind of acted like she took Ellie from
that you know facility or this off of
just face the show not the game but you
know she took them out of that program
that she was in that was in episode six
or seven I think it was seven and that's
the way they kind of made a scene they
might have made it seem like she snapped
like it's not tez who was the other
person
um uh not Marlene Marlene yeah it's
Marlene Marlene yeah yeah so it kind of
made me feel like Marlene snatched her
from that program and that's the first
that's how she knew her so it's kind of
weird how they kind of you know
backtracked that a little bit a couple
episodes like no I've known you your
whole life
you know so that kind of didn't seem
didn't seem good to me that part but
besides that and I think that was more
about explaining why Ellie's mune
because she was bit while she's being
born and it does look like you know some
of that that immunity somehow
transferred from uh to her through the
umbilical cord before they cut the
umbilical cord right uh so that I
understand why they did that so that's
fine I felt like the hospital scene was
extremely well done it showed because
here's what I think the whole episode
the whole season everyone is saying how
they scared of Joe how Joe is this this
this beast and no one wants to mess with
Joel but I didn't feel like they were
doing that Justice and everyone is
scared of Joe but Joe's never doing
anything in the show but they set it up
well
because when Marlene you know
um all right so right before right after
that scene okay she has to kill Ellie's
moms because Ellie moms is gonna change
and she told her please shoot me
um
and you know she Marlene hands the baby
over to a soldier and he says cover her
heirs
and Marlene goes in there like a
cold-blooded killer and Pops off and
this Soldier did not cover the baby is
but um
on on while they on the highway walking
uh Ellie Ellie is distracted man she's
distracted this whole way though she's
distracted
and he's he's trying to talk to her man
because Joe right now really knows how
much this kid means to him and he's
trying to you know get to her but it's
just not happening and they get a chance
to see some giraffes
and then seeing these giraffes
um Ellie starts to
you know come around
and that's a great scene from the game
and you know he's talking to her as
they're walking after the giraffes and
he tells her that he tried to kill
himself
and um
because she was like you know because he
said it was a guy that uh just shot at
him and missed and she's like well is
she a bad shot and that was early on you
know I think it was like second third
episode
um and um
he's like no I tried to kill myself
because after his daughter died he had
no reason to live he had no reason to go
on because that was his sole purpose in
this world
and then he tried to kill himself and um
he realized now he has a purpose
and you know she's sitting there she's
the purpose and
that that that that that that kind of
hit like that part hit
because the way he said it the way they
phrased it the way the scene was lit
and then right after that you know uh
flash bang boom cracked in the head
snatched up and uh Marlene is talking to
Joe like whoa whoa whoa be easy
and she she tells them you know how did
you get it how did you make it here
I I lost men coming here I wouldn't have
made I almost died getting here how did
you make it here
and um
he was just like you know like
to him it's effortless survival to Joel
is like breathing survival to Joe is
like a fishing water
survival to Joe means there ain't no
infected around you came across three or
four people the entire time there's a
reason okay look there's this can you go
out of more you like it's a game called
Fallout New Vegas all right this is what
this reminds me no in Fallout New Vegas
made by obsidian that at the beginning
they're like look if you want to go to
New Vegas we recommend this path because
this path is the safest path don't go up
because you'll get killed don't go left
or right because you'll get killed you
want to take this road all the way
around the whole map straight to Vegas
because you will not make it unless you
go any other way and I'm sitting here
looking at this like that's exactly what
job did Joe took because if you don't
remember a deer in the whole the whole
movie the whole TV show they're like
we're gonna go this way because it's
safer yeah Marlene probably want the
most dumb way possible she could have
went and a lot of that is knowledge you
know they've always said Joel to be he's
been doing this a long time he knows
what areas are safe what areas are not
safe
attic I'm gonna beg to differ I'm gonna
fight back on this
Joel almost died man
Jones died I give you that but
there ain't no cat with that knife in
his stomach
and that girl helped him survive and I
told you that episode where they had to
both have their individual battles to
make it out of a situation and they came
together and you're not together they
are absolutely uh terrible Force man
they're a real strong force
and
she told those dudes
when she told Joe what's gonna happen to
her Joel's sitting there looking at that
moment she already know Joel in his and
Joe gonna bust off these shots if you
get a chance to get a gun
she's like walk this dude over the damn
bridge and give him his bag and if he's
so happens to Flinch put a bullet in his
head
huh
I guess they should have listened
because
your boy got em
and he goes through that hospital
Like a Surgeon
Precision a man on fire I'm talking
about
this is what the game is about because
that's how I felt when I was having when
I had to take that that whole obstacle
course to get to that girl to get to
that that lab to get to that prep room
that surgery table that
I was a Man on Fire
and I and I felt that he had that that
face the determination the scenes was
lit and the whole time I'm watching I'm
like I know attic is going bananas
that's the whole thing I'm saying the
whole time I know attic is going bananas
because it was good it was a good scene
yes yes it was it because that made me
convinced that that's Joel like there
was a one time in the first episode
where Joe was trying to get the battery
from that dude and he traded him with
the medicine or whatever you traded him
with and Joe was like looked at him like
stared him down like saw through his
soul that is who Joe was not not whoever
Pedro was the like the end the beginning
that's Joe the N that show all of this I
don't know who that is but it wasn't
Joel that was Pedro pretending to be Joe
that's where all this was and Joe
beginning Joe all this take that take
that stuff to Mandalorian we don't want
that here take that Mandalorian man you
got a mask on in that show anyway nobody
gonna know who you are
yo listen listen listen stop the cat
I'm gonna have to call catboy you man
you need texture you need layers you
need build up you need people to
understand there's a reason why he's
feared you're not gonna show your hand
early on
hey he showed it when it mattered
everybody had guns this boy was going
through Grand Theft Auto style when my
clips and everything went out me if I
kill you and I'm gonna grab your gun and
work you down
nah man hey that that
was that would that was what it was
supposed to be anybody played the game
and if you didn't I know you ran out to
get that game after that because
he lit it up and that doctor tried to do
the whole Hornswoggle talk that whole
listen here I'm ready to [__] shut up
man
yo cold blooded
it was the best
the best Bing
Chef's best kiss
Chef kiss man I'm talking about the bill
first of all he showed you how
vulnerable he is to that kid
is no way in hell he was leaving that
hospital without her and
the fact that they did everything even
the after in the car
where he had to get the lie on
on God and a man that was probably the
best episode that kept it real I'm
talking about gave you heart
gave you purpose gave you Ellie's origin
boy I don't know how they gonna top this
one here boy Last of Us two gonna be
fantastic
I'm about this this this
I'm gonna watch it again
it was that damn good
keep talking someone's calling me okay
y'all know
when Ellie's in the backseat of the car
right
I'm laughing and my wife is is like why
are you laughing so much I said those
hospital gowns ain't got no backs
but at the same time
she asked him you know
all that stuff at the hospital because
she had she had a sneaking suspicion
that
this dude ain't gonna let it go like he
ain't gonna let her die
and she was willing to die for that call
she was willing to Die to Save the World
and Joel just wasn't ready to lose
another kid
like he went through all this life
with missing that one piece that that
father like when you're a dad like a dad
and you lose your kid I pray that I
never understand how that feels
but
he lost like he said purpose and he was
going to blow his brains out and then
to realize that now he has purpose
now
he didn't care about all that stuff in
the middle all the stuff that happened
he didn't care about the life that
happened in the middle of the hard part
of that life
because this part is the part
that actually means something
and this part is he he's he would be
willing to go through that just to get
to that part where his life has meaning
and he just wanted to get her back to
family where they because when they got
over the Ridge and he saw the Ridge and
he's like see that there it is
you know we made it back
and he's going to get back to Tommy
he's going to get back to the whole
family Maria and them
and uh she's gonna have a life
he wants to teach you how to play guitar
he has goals now
and the goals include her
so he lost being a father now he's a dad
again he's a father again and everybody
saw it all the way through he had the
parental feeling that Parental Guidance
that parental protection
there
it was there
and it's just this episode
even even the last this episode before
that this guy got a gut wound
he gets up and he's killing to get to
this kid
I'm telling you
that's the feeling of a dad protecting
his Cubs
I definitely understand the concept
behind it but I felt like to show didn't
do a good job building that that
that relationship up until he got the uh
the injury
um I I personally feel like it was a hit
and miss every episode they had some
good moments and other episodes it felt
like it was forced I do feel like the
injury did a really good job on building
that that uh that relationship but I'm
gonna be with you but by that time
I didn't see enough character
development between them two to think
Joel would Scorch the Earth for her in
that in that in that place I just didn't
I knew that after
after she risked everything
after she told him right before they was
going to Tommy
what he meant to her
you know I
could see where see here's the thing I
could see where someone would feel that
way and what someone would uh would see
that I just personally don't see that
you listen I feel you
um
because in the game they had a lot of
opportunities that was in that game that
built up to that decision but you're
talking about but they took all that out
of the game Phila you have to but but
this isn't just filler like the bill
episode where they they were constantly
ganging up on Ellie and then you know
Joe started taking up for Ellie these
are building blocks that show to why she
decided to stay with him when he got
injured I felt like they took a lot of
those building blocks out of the show
I I feel you I'm not saying that they
didn't
the the bill of Frank episode
they wanted to give bill
the layers that they they couldn't give
in the game
you know um they wanted to give Frank
some texture to understand why this guy
who prepped his whole life and and as a
survivalist uh
was willing to stop his world to include
somebody else that he just met
you know um
he was willing to take a chance risk it
all
so I mean these these tangible uh
connections that these individuals
making in this post-apocalyptic
Whirlwind it makes no sense to make any
type of connections
they have to give a texture
I'm just saying I'm just advocating for
for for each episode because the third
episode is the episode I really liked
that episode
I don't care where anybody stands on uh
anyone's sexuality I don't care where
anybody is I I don't have issues with it
because I know that part I know you I
know you don't care about that
and please
I care more about the Integrity of the
cat the Integrity of the character and
the changing
okay first like you can literally say
getting rid of that character does
nothing to the overall plot of the show
like getting rid of that episode does
nothing to the show at all and to me
that's not true okay then explain
besides the relationship between Joe and
and and then and uh you know those two
characters Frank and and Bill which
didn't really care over anything because
they didn't really talk about them after
that episode that was it they were done
they were dead
how do you get but you could they could
literally have just found that that car
at that point
yeah but you didn't get to text you oh
no okay here's the thing here's the
thing you didn't appreciate the the gift
that uh Neil druckman gave you no I I
didn't it was a soured episode man it
was like they took they took someone as
iconic as Bill
someone that had a lot of Charisma
forgot about someone in the video game
someone that was that that was damaged
someone that you could relate to and
they completely rewrote his character
now it's like I said episode three
towards the end I thought okay Frank's
about to die they rewrote that but I can
understand why they're gonna explain why
bill was acting the way bill is
and then like oh he he had the he had
the the the pills in the bottle too and
he's about to die too I'm like oh so we
can even get a bill and Ellie and Joe I
to me it's just not acceptable that's
what you was upset with it is no way on
this planet and I'm gonna go back to it
if my significant other is dying and I
just gave him or her poisoning
you're basing this off of your character
yourself
but here's the thing they're not basing
this bill off some random character they
wrote they're basing this bill off a
character that's already established in
another franchise and you you welcome to
the Multiverse oh my God see why can't
we just say they shouldn't have done
that but I like the way it ended okay
for you they shouldn't have done that
but I like the way it ended I like I
don't remember him
okay so Mass produces the game feels
like the game feels like a road trip
movie I I love it yes
here's the thing
I just don't like the decisions they
made in certain areas that took away
from other aspects of the game that led
up to what happened in the in the game
like it's just like to me you could have
easily and I think that the biggest
issue the biggest corporate was only
there's only Nine episodes but they had
they had this is the the biggest budget
at HBO TV show they've ever done
so clearly they could have done more the
the person who the person who directed
it had a good track record so I'm pretty
sure they could have got more off of HBO
they could have done more from this but
they looked at this script
and I'm sorry
it's it's like what would you okay let's
go to the overall show uh because we do
at the end this here soon what would you
give the overall show in terms of
popcorns five
if I can throw some extra butter and
some caramel in there with a little bit
of peanuts and man I'm telling you
that episode had every last drop of
ingredients
it is
it is it is
if if you've seen only one episode
one episode
if if you could only watch one episode
out of this whole series
watch the last one because it gave you
everything right there
um
there you go all those popcorn
fantastical
I'm gonna give it a three
like I wanna give it a three I want to
give them a four but I can't I can't
this this show was about this this show
was about a infected world
there was no infected pretty much the
entire show and hundreds of them that
popped under the ground I've done one
episode they had a bunch of showed off
the bloater never came back in the show
the last episode didn't even have
infected so it's here look there's a
bloater in uh in the the tunnel hold up
there's a there's a bloater in the
tunnel right before they got to the
hospital in the game they could have
easily have recreated that scene and had
that rematch with the bloater and stuff
but they didn't want to do that so it's
just like they went straight into the
hospital they cut the majority of the
game when it come to affected out and I
didn't like that I I didn't like the
fact that it's equivalent I'm sorry
walking dead because I see a lot of
people comparing this to The Walking
Dead Season one Walking Dead Season one
compared to the last of a season one
Walking Dead shits all over the last of
us it's not even remotely in the same
ball field walk last of us is
no The Walking Dead is prime time that
that Prime Steak and Last of Us is like
the generic chicken the the the the the
the the movie theater go straight do you
like this you like the simp Sheriff that
came to play babies Daddy to his own
Daddy get the hell out of here man
the whole that whole Walking Dead is
capped because we're dead
if I'd have found out what was happening
so all of that is capped ain't none of
that real if Joe was the sheriff and he
came back and he saw his wife with this
dude that was his man that left him in
the hospital for dead everybody dying
ain't no way in hell no see you you're
sitting here you speaking here it's not
gonna happen oh so it's okay so so
what's funny what's hilarious about this
this thing I'm not I'm not co-signing
Sims no
no you sitting there you're you're
trying to to to single out one or two
characters in here there is so much good
things about The Walking Dead Season one
I'm talking about that first episode it
doesn't matter we're talking about the
whole season okay so check it check it
first episode that's where they lost me
episode
okay this shows multiple episodes Lost
me so what's your point I got you I got
you what's your point I walked away
first episode I said this is The Walking
Dead
I'd rather watch the the first the
entire series of The Walking Dead before
I watched that season again
I call cat oh no I would rather watch
look there was a lot of
the the worst season of The Walking Dead
is is on par with the last of us okay
I'm gonna go that far listen all right
all right whatever man
um
I know that you'll be Tuning In For The
Last of Us season too well obviously I
have to because of this damn show
got him
nah it's just dude the show it just it
wasn't it they they they butchered a lot
of of the lore that had come to The Last
of Us I think it's a decent show I'm not
gonna say it's a bad show but it's a
decent show it is what it is but it's
just like it's like I said
other shows that's in the same vein that
it's in almost all of them are better
almost all of them are better
uh listen I feel you
I thought it was really good like I
think this is a great episode of RNR
with the Lords me and how to go at it
oh I mean we go at it but at the end of
the day I'm right you're wrong okay Halo
listen see it Halo is like a two out of
five okay this is like a three out of
five you know I just watched Chucky the
the second season of checking that's
like a that's a three out of five two it
wasn't a great
y'all cannot take movie advice from a
dude to watch the series of Chucky I'm
sorry don't let this man lie to you that
that's a fun show see
see you want to take uh uh what should I
watch this evening
the series no it's not gonna happen cap
we're gonna close out of here
because uh King is enjoying himself a
little too much
[Music]
yo don't forget guys yo go check out my
boy's book uh igniting initiative my boy
Chris Barton
um he's uh down with uh my statue group
dcx uh not mine but Lord Vader statue
group I'm just a part of it I'm a uh uh
member family member so
um listen guys
what the hell happened daddy we gone no
it's still alive I see yeah no it did
something weird
I think the popcorn is going crazy yeah
they they kept I had to like manually
turn them off yeah it did something nuts
yo um yeah guys this week I'm gonna go
see Shazam so I definitely gonna check
you guys out on Tuesday uh I've got to
find something for attic to watch on
Netflix on Hulu on Paramount on
something uh but uh we definitely got to
get him to watch something because I
don't think he's gonna get a chance to
go see Shazam this week you're not gonna
get a chance to see that right
um I'ma try it just depends maybe after
Grace picks me up from the airport
Sunday we can come on the way back we
could just stop by and watch it I don't
know how she'll feel about that well
we're gonna okay so it comes out
tomorrow yeah so we're gonna do a show
on Tuesday
but I'll be we'll be gone all week no we
don't leave until Wednesday
yeah oh yeah you're right I'm thinking a
week ahead yeah we're gonna leave till
Wednesday
I mean do we really want to have a show
next week though yeah yeah I do yeah I
do because I I gotta get up early the
next day and uh you see Atticus trying
to cheat you guys of a show man
and I'm trying to give y'all that raw
uncut baby I'm trying to make sure that
you you get this you you gotta have
something to get through that week cause
we're not gonna have a show on Sunday
man it cannot be like that can't be
can't I be like that man we'll figure it
out we'll figure it out yeah Shazam
Tuesday Shazam
would you you guys have a good day we're
gonna go ahead and uh caught up out of
here I do think that um well God react
to that season two real quick because
it's only like a minute and a half long
but I appreciate for coming through uh
that will be on patreon sometime today
and until next week what's up until next
time Shazam
you're ridiculous
[Music]
thank you
foreign